la tension monte au sujet de la 5g alors
que le groupe iliad maison mère de
l'opérateur free souhaite que le
gouvernement clarifie sa position sur
les équipementiers autorisé pour le
déploiement de la 5g l'ambassade de
chine en france a mis en garde paris ce
dimanche sur d'éventuelles mesures
discriminatoires qu'on trouve à hawaii
pékin se dit inquiet et choqué le
président emmanuel macron et d'autres
hauts responsables français ont
réaffirmé à plusieurs reprises que sur
la question de la 5g la france ne
prendrait pas de mesures
discriminatoires contre un pays ou une
entreprise spécifique ni n'exclure et
huawei donc si les informations
susmentionnées des médias français
s'avèrent exacts c'est visiblement
contraire à l'engagement pris par le
gouvernement français fin janvier
l'union européenne avait ouvert
partiellement sa porte à huawei pour
développer la 5g défiant ainsi les
etats-unis qui accusent l'équipementier
d'espionnage au profit de pékin
mais cette mise en garde de la chine à
la france pourrait avoir des
conséquences à l'échelle internationale
sur le déploiement de la 5g si par
hasard quelques pays européens la france
la chine serait obligé la machine
arrière sur le développement de la salle
j'ai bien joué et ça permettrait aux
entreprises européennes avec tout
bénéfice pour l'europe de mutualiser
leurs besoins et mutualiser le
déploiement la de la salle j'ai un peu
moins bien plus cher mais deux autres
opérateurs hexagonaux sfr et bouygues
telecom utilise notamment des
équipements de huawei sur le réseau
actuel leurs annonces sur la 5g sont
attendus dans les semaines prochaines
après validation par les autorités
françaises
[Musique]